Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast-Ufo mit Stefan T. Schön, dass du mit dabei seid. Vielen, vielen Dank natürlich auch an dieses grandiose Intro, über das wir uns sehr gefreut haben und freudig mitgeschunkelt haben. Unser Körper ist in Wallung von diesem tollen Intro von DHXP und vielleicht dem jungen, neuen, aufstrebenden Hip-Hop-Star, den wir begrüßen dürfen in diesem neuen Jahr. Hallo. Florentin W. ist auch wieder mit dabei. Auch er startet dieses Jahr 2022. Und ich finde, dieses Intro ist jetzt eine ganz gute Messlatte für alle Intros, die jetzt dieses Jahr noch kommen. Ja. Weil das wird euer Jahr, Jahr, das Introjahr. Da meine ich euch, die noch ein Intro dazu steuern wollen. Wir sind quasi das erweiterte Intro für dieses neue Jahr, in das ihr gut reinkommen sollt. Hoffentlich herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. In diesem neuen Jahr eine Menge Zweien, so viele Zweien wie lange nicht mehr gehabt und auch bald nicht mehr kommen werden. Denkt dran, bis zum 16. Januar muss man frohes neues Jahr wünschen, danach nicht mehr. Danach nicht mehr. Ich finde es generell auch noch zu lang, aber wer sind wir im Larry David zu widersprechen? Nein, sind wir nicht. Es wurde ein Machtwort gesprochen und daran halten wir uns denn besser ein schlechtes Machtwort als kein Machtwort. Da zeigt er auf mich. Hier, was? Nee, komm, wir hauen schon Machtwörter raus. Ab und zu, ab und zu.
Wenn es niemand anders macht.
Aber ich halte mich ein bisschen zurück,
Machtwort zu sprechen.
DHXP.
DHXP heißt ...
Kann man den live sehen?
Ich hoffe doch, ich hoffe doch.
Livestreams oder sowas, googelt auf jeden Fall mal.
Ich hoffe, dass es nicht irgendeine schlimme Erbkrankheit ist,
die irgendwie ganz unangenehme Bilder hervorruft.
Weiß ich nicht, vielleicht ist es eine große Trollaktion.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist 2022 das Jahr der großen Trollaktion, vielleicht fallen wir alle auf einen großen Prank rein. Ich tüfte lange schon einen Tweet rum, den ich wahrscheinlich nie raushauen werde, weil ich glaube, der versteht niemand und vielleicht ist er einfach auch ein Kackgag. Aber manchmal kennt man diese Sachen, wo man sich drein verliebt. Ja, man bleibt hängen. Weil ich finde ja so lustig, weil alle gemeint haben, Hamilton, weil es ein Hip-Hop-Musical war, hat das Musical wieder cool gemacht. Aber ich denke die ganze Zeit, ich würde es gerne umdrehen. Für mich hat Hamilton Hip-Hop wieder cool gemacht. Aber I don't know, man. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich auch nicht. Lass los, Stefan, lass los. Ja, aber ich weiss es. Lass los.
Und davon habe ich so bestimmt 150 ungelogen Tweets, die ähnlich schlecht sind, von denen ich aber nicht lösen kann.
Ich dachte, ja, das ist wie ein Rätsel auf.
Im Entwurf-Ordner bei Twitter.
Aber das kannst du ja mal so veröffentlichen, so als Booklet, als Buch, als Flyer, einfach die unveröffentlichten Tweets, so die zweite Reihe.
Tweet-Dump.
Ja, die große zweite Reihe der Twitter-Notizblock. Glaub ich, kennt jeder. Einfach hier, bieb. Steffans Tweetdump. Vielleicht mal gut am Anfang des Jahres mal so eine, einfach mal putzen, die Rohre reinigen. Ja, mal alles durchwischen. Ich glaube, die ersten Tage des neuen Jahres hat man eh so einen Freifahrtschein. Da kann man einfach mal raushauen, einfach mal so ein bisschen die Schlacke rausballern und ansonsten geht das schon weiter. Ich fange erst frühestens im Februar zu arbeiten. Ja. Und dann hört man ja auch wieder auf, im November hört man wieder auf zu arbeiten. Ja. Ich sag mal, erst mal reinkommen, erst mal reinkommen, klarkommen. Ja, reinkommen, erst mal gucken, wie hat es funktioniert mit den Vorsätzen, funktioniert das, kriege ich das hin einigermaßen oder soll man schon das über Bord werfen. Weil Vorsätze sind ja so ein bisschen wie so ein Heißluftballonspfad, man nimmt so Gewichte mit, um sie dann im richtigen Moment wegwerfen zu können. Weil viele Leute sagen ja, Vorsätze sind dumm, sind schlecht, weil man sie ja eh bricht, ja, aber das Brechen macht ja wahnsinnig viel Spaß und das ist ja ein schöner Moment, dass wenn man sich am Anfang des Jahres diesen Ballast mitnimmt, ist dann im richtigen Moment abwerfen zu können. Das ist ja immer so in jedem guten Heißluftballon Action Film, in jeder guten Heißluftballons Verfolgungsjagd, wie wir sie kennen, gibt es ja immer den Moment, wo jemand sagt Ballast abwerfen und man denkt sich, das heißt wir hatten die ganze Zeit Ballast dabei, der uns bis jetzt zurückgehalten hat. Warum nehmen wir überhaupt Ballast mit?
Sehr dramatisierend auch, wenn sie dich runterwerfen wollen, statt die Sandsäcke, weil sie noch das Gefühl haben, dass die Sandsäcke im Laufe des Abenteuers noch von grösserer Bedeutung sein können. Ja genau, und da denkt man sich, genau diese Art von Ballast sind gute Vorsätze fürs neue Jahr, die niemand hält, natürlich nicht, aber du kannst sie im richtigen Moment abwerfen, wenn es heißt, jetzt muss ich Ballast abwerfen, jetzt muss was raus, dann kann man die schön raushauen. Zu viel Stress, jetzt mal diese ganze Abnehm-Scheiße abwerfen. Ja genau, oh fuck, irgendetwas Schlimmes passiert und man sagt, jetzt muss Ballast abgewerfen worden, dann lass uns mal zwei von den drei Vorsätzen rauswerfen, ist immer gut. Ähm, damals gab's doch dieses Problem, als es das Jahre Null schlug, 2000.
Ähm, da gab's doch dieses Grosste ...
Ich erinnere mich gut. Ja, ich wollte dich fragen. Das war eine Partei. Warst du alt genug? Das war eine Partei. Eine Partei. Ich war neun Jahre alt und ich bin meinem Bruder hinterher gelaufen, der hatte so eine Papierschlange mit so Wunderkerzen drin, dass wenn man die angezündet hat, dann wackelt die so mit dem Kopf und ich dachte mir, holy fucking Christ, wir sind in der Zukunft angekommen, ich werde es nie vergessen und ich habe es tatsächlich nie vergessen, anders als die hunderten anderen Momente, wo ich dachte, das werde ich nie vergessen und ich habe es offensichtlich vergessen. Ja und häufig sogar zehn Minuten danach. Denkt mal nach, wie viele Dinge könnt ihr euch erinnern, wo ihr euch dachtet, das werde ich nie vergessen. Null, wenn es null sind, dann habt ihr mindestens einmal gelogen, euch selbst an, und das ist ja das Schlimmste. Die schlimmsten Lügen erzählt man sich selbst. Ja, das ist auch unser Vorsatz gewesen, dass wir ein bisschen philosophischer werden, ein bisschen mehr so Kalendersprüche raushauen dieses Jahr. Ein bisschen mehr T-Shirt-Sprüche einfach. Wir brauchen für unser Merch noch ein bisschen Motto-Shirts, noch ein paar T-Shirt-Sprüche, deswegen sind wir da dabei. Aber was wäre denn jetzt, das Problem war doch damals, da warst du ja mit neun Jahren finde ich alt genug, um das zu checken, man hatte Angst vor den vielen Nullen, richtig? Und man dachte, die Welt resettet sich und die Banken löschen alles Geld. Eine sehr komische, irrationale Angst gewesen, dieses Millennium-Null-Null-Problem. Ich glaube, da gibt es von Computertechnischen durchaus sinnvollen Hintergrund, weil irgendwie, ich weiss nicht genau, aber in Office Space, glaube ich, geht es auch darum, dass die immer nur die zweiten, die Office US oder UK? Nee, den Film Office Space mit Ron Livingston.
Nee, mach einfach
was. Du,
mach die Notizen gerne wieder zu.
Twitter da.
Ich habe extra da hingelenkt. Und die auch
meinten, dass die ja statt 19, also in all ihren
Daten statt 1999
immer nur 99 geschrieben haben.
Und das jetzt mit 2000 alles auf
Null fallen würde und es dann Schwierigkeiten gibt, weil dann irgendwie, wenn man mit Null multipliziert, kommt ... Wer wollte denn mit 99 multiplizieren? Keine Ahnung! Das ist ein Comedy-Film. Neben dem Lachen habe ich mal kurz drüber nachgedacht. Und du kannst auch mit Null multiplizieren. Die Sache ist, du kannst nicht durch Null teilen. Was weiss ich denn? Ich glaube, da gab es wirklich ein Problem. Ich da war dann, ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass damals irgendwie so ein reißerischer Medienbericht war. Und dann wurde wirklich so ein Informatiker interviewt, der meinte, ja, das stimmt schon, aber das ist eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem. Also genau wie du gerade mit einer ähnlichen Abgebrühtheit. Und dann im Beitrag war es dann, ja, das stimmt schon, oh, der Cut, scharfer Cut. Weil so macht man diese Beiträge nämlich.
Ich hör nicht mehr auf Informatiker.
Ja, nee, weg. Panik schürende
Informatiker sind für mich
wirklich die Loser des Jahres 2021.
Wenn du die Cookies nicht akzeptierst,
dann wenigstens mal, hör mir,
lass mich in Ruhe da.
Passwort, Passwort, hat der einen Knall?
SSL-Abfrage,
lass mich in Ruhe
mit dem Quatsch. Aber warum diese
sehr spezifische Gruppe der panik schürenden
In Passwort hat der einen Knall? SSL-Abfrage, jetzt lass mich in Ruhe mit dem Quatsch! Aber warum diese sehr spezifische Gruppe der panikschürenden Informatiker, für mich die Loser des Jahres 2021 sind, ist eher der Grund. Ja, Flop 1. Flop 1? Wir machen ja heute einen kleinen Jahresrückblick. Flop 1? Flop 1, unsere Flop 1 ist... Panikschürende Informatiker können mir gestohlen bleiben. Weißt du, warum die bei mir Flop 1 sind Wegen der ganzen Facebook-Sache. Als Facebook für zwei Stunden offline war, und dann haben doch so Informatiker bei Twitter dann irgendwie den Source-Code gesehen und da wurde was gelöscht und dann was dann geschickt und dann gesagt, hier die Server sind komplett gewiped, wenn es das ist, wonach es aussieht, wie es gerade aussieht, dann wird Facebook nie wieder online können. Und das war Facebook, wie wir es kannten, ist für immer Geschichte. Drei Stunden später ganz normal wieder online, ja. Und auch so Informatiker, denen ich traue, die irgendwie an der ETH Zürich studieren und Informatiker sind und da auch so Tutoren. Fickt euch! Die haben mir gesagt, das ist ein großes Problem und ich habe mich schon mit Popcorn vor den Fernseher gesetzt und dachte jetzt gleich, schalten die da einen Brennpunkt um und sagen, dass Facebook gewiped ist und die Welt, wie sie kennen. Nein! Panik schürende Informatiker, Flop. Ja, absoluter Flop eins für mich auch. Thema Passwörter, irgendwie immer 64-stellige Passwörter, muss nicht sein, einfach immer diese übertriebene Sicherheitsabfrage,
nee, interessiert mich nicht, interessiert mich nicht.
Ich meine, ich habe mittlerweile so
ein Programm, das meine Passwörter speichert,
deshalb auch immer so Passwörter vorschlägt,
wo ich mir einfach denke, chill
mal bitte dein scheiß Leben gerade,
wenn du dich irgendwie bei Letterbox
anmelden willst, was einfach eine Liste
ist an Filmen, die du gesehen hast, und der schlägt dir ein 18 Zeichen Passwort vor, wo ich mir denke, entspann dich mal, fortnox. Damit man dein unveröffentlichtes Review von Office Space nicht gucken kann. Das ist wirklich wie wenn du so eine halb Meter dicke Stahltür an deinen Schuppen bauen würdest, wo irgendwie drei Rechen und ein Bienennest drin ist. Und er auch denkt so, ganz ruhig, okay, niemand will da rein, niemand will da rein. Das ist wie damals unser Gitarrist, der mehr Geld ausgegeben hat für die Cases, die seine Gitarren und seine super billigen Boxen beherbergt haben. Und er irgendwann so coolen Cases haben wollte, which I get. Ich verstehe die Idee, coole Cases zu wollen, aber nicht, wenn sie etwas beinhalten, was sehr billig ist. Ja, wenn das Schloss doppelt so teuer ist wie dein Fahrrad und am Ende nur das Schloss geklaut wird und das Fahrrad einfach stehen gelassen wird, das ist auch schon passiert. Vielleicht wird aber mein Jahr 22 wieder ein Fahrradjahr. Ich hatte ja lange ein Fahrrad, bis ich es mir selber geklaut habe quasi. Ich habe es festgeschnallt mit meinem Schloss und dann ging das Schloss kaputt, eingerostet.
Das ist wie das Passwort vergessen, das analoge Passwort vergessen.
Und dann habe ich versucht, es mit dem Löffel aufzuknacken, mein Schloss, was nicht geklappt hat, überhaupt nicht.
Nee, aber das hat ja vorher gesagt, der Löffel hat ja schon wahrscheinlich auch gedacht, what is happening?
Ich weiß noch wie, damals, als ich mich als Kind ausgesperrt habe und ich hatte damals aber schon eine Geldkarte, ich hatte schon ein Konto und eine Geldkarte. Ach so, ich dachte auch da, wer Löffel deine erste Idee gewesen ist. Nee, dann dachte ich mir, ich habe im Film schon oft gesehen, wie Leute mit einer Karte einfach so an der Tür rumnackeln und dann geht die auf und ich dachte mir, mach ich jetzt auch unkoordiniert einfach irgendwo mit der Karte herumgestochert, ohne zu wissen, was jetzt hier passieren soll, habe ich es tatsächlich nicht geschafft, die Tür zu öffnen.
Welcher coolste, ein der coolste Momente meines Lebens war, wie ich mal eine Schublade aufgebrochen habe von einem Schreibtisch mit einer Büroklammer.
Wird ich genauso unkoordiniert, du hast auch schon mal einen Film gesehen, dass mir eine Büroklammer so aufklappt, dann hast du so einen kleinen Draht und dann so unkoordiniert rumpröckeln, bis es dann irgendwann aufgeht und genau so ging es. Ich habe unkoordiniert mit der Büroklammer rumgepröckelt und irgendwann ging halt diese Schublade auf. Wahnsinn. Ja, und das war wirklich so cool, wo ich dachte, holy shit, holy cow, holy cow. Ist das das ganze Geheimnis von Schlüsseldiensten, die kriegen 400 Euro dafür, dass sie einfach, du sagst pröckeln, ich sag nackeln. Nackeln hab ich noch nie gehört. Ja, das wahrscheinlich auch... Wie schreibst du es? K, N, U, C, K? Nackeln, ja, wie Nackels. Ist ähnlich so wie Hassel eigentlich. Aber Nackeln einfach so halt so rumfummeln. Ah, Fummeln ist nicht das richtige Wort. Es ist schon eine unkoordinierte Bewegung, die irgendwo reingeht. So rein Nackeln. Benutzt man es in einem anderen Kontext, den du es kennst? Nackeln? Nee, so wie du gerade, was hast du gesagt? Pröckeln. Pröckeln, das habe ich wiederum nicht gehört. Benutzt man Nackeln in einem anderen Kontext. Wo kennst du es noch? Hey, wenn es nicht geht, dann musst du es so ein bisschen rumnackeln, dann baust du es schon wieder. Dann baust du es schon wieder. So halt einfach so ein bisschen, ja, rumzettern. Rumpröckeln. Ja, pröckeln, ja, kann schon sein. Finde ich ein gutes Wort eigentlich. Das war so ein Wörteraustausch. Das ist immer so, jeder bringt sein Wort an den Tisch und wir tauschen uns gegenseitig aus, welches Wort wollen wir nehmen. Finde ich gut. Nehme ich mal Mackeln mit. Habe aber einen tollen Prank gesehen, könnt ihr gerne imitieren. Und zwar, da hat jemand, lebt in einer Beziehung, glücklicher Beziehung, junges Paar. Und dann hat er die Seife der Freundin ausgetauscht mit einer Kartoffel. Aber die hat er so geschnitzt, dass sie so aussieht wie ein Stück Seife. Dann hat er die ausgetauscht und hat die Freundin versucht, sich das Gesicht zu waschen mit der Seife. Und er hat gesagt, das ist eine Kartoffel. Er hat die Freundin gesagt, verdammt noch eins. Das glaub ich dir jetzt nicht. Also das glaub ich nicht. Da könntest du mich jetzt wirklich, hättest du mich jetzt umtotschlagen können, hättest du mich jetzt umtotschlagen können, hättest du mich nicht draufgekommen. Da wär ich beim besten Willen, hätt ich's nicht geahnt. Ich hätte es nicht geahnt. Und er kichert und lacht und also heitere Szene, alles in allem. Auch wenn die Dialoge sind. So stelle ich mir die an Weihnachten vor. Am Weihnachtsabend an dem Tisch stelle ich mir vor, wie du so sprichst und man denkt so, kannst du kurz die Reis geben, bitte?
Und du sagst, nee, ganz kurz noch und dann lass mich die Geschichte noch zu Ende erzählen. Während der andere die ausgestreckte Hand konstant hat und nicht weiß, ab wann man die wieder runternimmt, sag ich, nee, lass mich dir noch kurz eine Szene erzählen, die ich erlebt habe. Ich war nicht selber dabei, aber ich habe sie gesehen im Internet. und ja, fand ich einen tollen Prank und da habe ich nachgedacht, ich war ja lange
eifriger Leser des Mickey Mouse War nicht selber dabei, aber ich habe es gesehen im Internet. Und ja, fand ich einen tollen Prank.
Und da habe ich nachgedacht, ich war ja lange eifriger Leser des Mickey-Maus-Magazins, wo auch oft solche Prank-Utensilien mit drin waren. Und ich habe mich nie getraut, den Prank zu machen. Ich kann mich sogar noch erinnern, dass in einer Mickey-Maus-Magazin-Ausgabe, und die Experten können gerne mir die Nummer nennen, Da war so ein Plastiknagel drin,
zweiteilig, so dass man
bei einer Glasscheibe das eine
Stück auf die eine, das andere Stück auf die andere
klebt, als wäre ein Nagel
durch die Scheibe geraten. Und dann war
sogar noch so ein Sticker dabei, den man
draufkleben kann, der so Risse zeigt.
Und das habe ich dann, und ich dachte mir,
das war ich, prank meine Eltern
total und da irgendwie so eine Küchenvitrine mit so einer Glasscheibe, hinter dem die Cornflakeschüssel sind, da mache ich dieses Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, ich dachte mir, Alter, das war ich. Prank meiner Eltern total und da irgendwie so eine Küchenvitrine mit so einer Glasscheibe, hinter dem die Cornflakeschüssel sind. Da mache ich diesen Nagel dran, habe den da dran gemacht und habe mich versteckt. Und ich war so voller Vorfreude und Energie und ich konnte kaum still sitzen, bis ich gesagt habe, nee Mann, das kannst du nicht machen. Das kannst du nicht machen. Und dann bin ich hingegangen und hab's wieder abgebaut. Ich bin bescheuert.
Lämste Mensch der ganzen Welt. Ich hab nie, der Prank nie aufgegangen.
Ich dachte mir, das kannst du nicht bringen, das kannst du nicht bringen.
Aber wieder schön abgemacht, abgefummelt, abgenackelt,
schön den Sticker und weggeworfen.
Ich hab aber auch immer so dolle Fremdscharm-Gefühle bei solchen Pranks.
Also ich guck die gern, aber die Hälfte ist gern gucken, die andere Hälfte ist, ich mache den Laptop so runter, so leicht runter. Alles ist besser, wenn man es angewinkelt sieht. Auch bei Horrorfilmen, immer schön Winkel, 30-Grad-Winkel. Aber wirklich auch so Curb Your Enthusiasm ist bei mir wirklich, Guck Vergnügen und Laptop Hype zu, beides in einem immer. Was ich letztes Jahr entdeckt habe, ist die Serie Liebe im Spektrum, glaube ich, heißt die, wo autistische Leute auf Dates gehen, weil die Schwierigkeiten haben mit sozialen Interaktionen und gerade Daten und sowas fällt ihnen natürlich sehr schwer und die dann aber auch mit anderen autistischen Menschen zusammenkommen. Und das ist sehr, sehr, sehr cool. Es sind alles coole Typen, alles tolle, interessante Persönlichkeiten. Und es ist sehr, sehr schön anzusehen, auch sehr süss und romantisch. Aber ich kann einfach nicht bei Dates zugucken. Es geht einfach nicht. Nee, bei Dates ist das Schlimmste. Es geht einfach nicht. Es ist einfach nicht möglich. Da muss ich wirklich den Raum verlassen. Und ich gucke teilweise aus der Küche so, ob die szenisch, ob die wieder in so einer Talking-Head-Situation sind. Ich kann es nicht ertragen. Es ist zu unangenehm. Auch wenn die Serie, glaube ich, sehr wenig, wie man sonst bei solchen Serien das kennt, dass die Leute aus dargestellt werden und sowas vorgeführt werden. Das war das Wort. Tief gesucht in der Wortschublade. Sehr zu empfehlen auf jeden Fall.
Und man bekommt auch eine grosse Menge an Verständnis für dieses Phänomen, auf jeden Fall, was das angeht. Ich will mal, es ist noch nicht so lange her, also ich muss die Wortwahl gut wählen, aber auf einem Date, und das ist dann bestimmt sehr schlimm für dich zu hören dann auch, weil ich verlasse kurz den Raum. Ich nehme dich kurz mit in diese Geschichte.
Und es war super nett und super lustig,
aber man hat sehr schnell gemerkt,
das wird wahrscheinlich nicht auf mehr hinaus.
Also zumindest ich habe gesagt,
ich werde sie bestimmt noch mal treffen und so weiter.
Und dann hat man halt dann noch,
kam dann die Kellnerin vorbei und sie wollte dann noch eine Runde bestellen.
Und dann hat sie noch,
bis mittags irgendwann hat sie noch einen Kaffee bestellt. Und ich habe gesagt, okay, dann hätte ich gerne noch einen Tee, habe ich einen Tee bekommen, also habe ich einen Tee bestellt und dann ging sie los und ich dachte mir, ja komm, dann trinken wir das schnell aus und so und dann zwei Getränke muss man schon machen, dass man das beide so zwei Drinks hatten jeweils und dann können wir gehen und so, dann hat man sich insgesamt irgendwie so eineinhalb Stunden, zwei Stunden unterhalten. Das ist ja irgendwie cool. Und dann kam mein Tee und es war nicht nur ein Tee, es war, und es war ja nicht zu ahnen, eine richtig grosse Kanne mit so drei Brühend heiß und obendrin waren so drei so Teebeutel in dieser großen Kanne.
Und dann war auch noch so ein Wärmelicht drunter, dass es nicht kalt wird.
Und dann hat die mir so eine Tasse hingestellt.
Und ich dachte mir, das kann auch nicht mehr.
Scheiße.
Aber ich habe so gesehen, ich habe so in Zeit gemessen.
Ja.
Gar nicht, dass es jetzt auch ein teureres Unterfangen wird.
Nein, ich habe einfach in Zeit, die wurden mir nicht, dass es jetzt auch ein teureres unterfangen wird, nein, ich habe einfach in Zeit
wurden mir gerade so zwei Stunden
noch on top gegeben.
Wo du einfach überlegst, was ist mir wichtiger,
meine Würde oder mein Gaumen?
Soll ich mich jetzt durch diese
Tee-Lava durchtrinken?
Ich habe es anders gemacht.
Ich bestelle oft Tees und dann auch so
alle gehen schon und man exzt es durch und
verbrennt sich den gesamten Innenraum seines Körpers.
Nee, ich habe eine andere Idee gehabt und die habe ich während des Smalltalks, der immer hölzer und wurde, weil ich immer mehr mir überlegt habe, wie komme ich in der Situation raus, kam ich dann auf die brillanten Gedanken, weil es war, du hast nicht gesehen, wie viel noch drin ist. Es war nämlich eine Keramik, es war so eine Keramikkanne. Und dann habe ich irgendwann einfach so getan, als wäre die leer. Und zwar habe ich irgendwann genau heraus, ich musste ein paar Mal natürlich nachgießen, dass ich so genau das Raussprudelverhalten gecheckt habe.
Und dann habe ich so beim dritten Mal, habe ich dann so getan, als wäre es ab unmerklich die Kanne gesenkt, damit der Schluss, der Fluss des Tees ein bisschen abgenommen hat und dann so getan, aber sehr leicht hinzustellen. Und ob es so getan ist, wäre die leer gewesen. Da war bestimmt noch drei Viertel drin. Fantastisch, aber wie gut, dass du plötzlich so eine komplette Sidequest hast und einfach die Kunst des Tee-Einschenkens meistern musst on the fly. Was für Fähigkeiten man auch plötzlich und welchen Enthusiasmus man auch entwickelt in solchen Momenten. Und wenn du hättest Chinesisch lernen müssen in der Stunde, um da rauszukommen, du hättest es getan. Easy. Ich glaube, ich stecke Menschen in blöde soziale Interaktionen und die werden erfinderisch hochtausend. Ich meine, das ist ja die moderne Version von Vor die tauchten Bär auf. Angst, Adrenalin gibt es ja heute nicht mehr oder oder kaum noch, sondern solche sozialen Situationen, Flucht, Reflex. Nee, fand ich super, war stolz auf mich, fand ich sehr lustig. Ja, finde ich eine gute Lösung, aber auch. Ja, ja, hab ich auch gedacht. So, dann, wichtig, wir haben nämlich ... Da müssen wir kurz hinlegen, danach. Sorry, wirklich, das ist ... Wir haben im letzten ... Eine kleine Sache, damit du dich ein bisschen entspannen kannst wieder.
Wir haben ja letztes Jahr eine grosse Verschwörungstheorie hier aufgestellt.
Nämlich, habe ich gesagt, ich behaupte, dass Leute, die bei Filmen arbeiten oder bei anderen Optikern, immer Brillen tragen müssen. Ja, richtig, dass die Augen ausgestochen werden, damit die eine Brille brauchen.
Genau, oder wenn du anders, wenn du einen Job willst, nochmal kurz irgendwie dreieinhalb Minuten in die Sonne gucken musst, damit du einen Job bekommst, weil du wirst ja keine Chance haben als Normalsichtiger. Ja. So, stellt sich raus, wir liegen gar nicht so falsch, denn uns hat geschrieben, der Daniel, er schreibt neun, kleine Bezugnahme zu der Fehlmannsituation. Ich hätte mal ein nettes Gespräch, übrigens sehr gut gemacht, nicht erst mal schreiben und dann muss man sich zusammenreimen aus dem Kontext, was meint er denn da? Nein, er hat direkt geschrieben, kleine Bezugnahme zu Filmsituationen. Vielen, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank, so macht man. Weil teilweise antworten auch Hörer auf zehn Folgen alte Folgen und gehen einfach davon aus, dass man weiß, worum es geht und wir vergessen es nach einer halben Stunde, nachdem wir es aufgenommen haben. Ist eigentlich eine drei plus, weil eigentlich hat er noch daneben zu schreiben, welche Folge.
Gut, aber das muss nicht sein.
Kleine Besuchung haben wir zur Firma Situation.
Der Versuch wird geadet.
Plus, ich glaube, das waren mehrere Folgen ein Thema.
Er schreibt, ich hatte mal ein nettes Gespräch mit einer Verkäuferin bei Vielmann,
die mir sagte, dass sie alle Brillen von dort kostenlos für die Arbeitszeit gestellt bekommt
und wenn man gesunde Augen hat, machen die einfach Gläser ohne
Dioptrien rein.
Nein, Fake-Brillen?
Fake-Brillen bei Vielmann.
Also ja, soweit ich im Bilde bin, tragen sie sich Fake-Brillen.
Ja, tatsächlich, wir haben auch Nachricht bekommen, ich glaube von einer Mitarbeiterin
oder ehemaligen Mitarbeiterin, die dann auch meinte, ja, man muss ja auch den Tragekomfort
kennen.
Bei der Brille geht es ja nicht nur um die Gläser, die sind ja eigentlich gerade für
so einen Brillenladen eher Nebensache, das ist ja Teil des Optikers.
Aber er ... Die dann auch meinte, ja, man muss ja auch den Tragekomfort kennen. Bei der Brille geht es ja nicht nur um die Gläser, die sind ja eigentlich gerade für so einen Brillenladen eher Nebensache, das ist ja Teil des Optikers, aber als Verkäufer oder Verkäuferin bei vielmann muss man ja die Bügelrahmen und den Tragekomfort kennen. Anfrage für spitze Nachfrage? Ja, bitte, eine spitze Anfrage von der Entize, von der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Samstagszeitung. Ah, alles klar.ontagszeitung. Denn ich würde gerne wissen, wenn Sie dann so eine Brille aufgesetzt haben und die gefällt Ihnen nicht vom Tragekomfort, und dann wollen Sie mir sagen, dass Sie diese Ray-Ban dann aus dem Sortiment nehmen? Nein, nein, nein, es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche, was heißt der Tragekomfort, das ist ja eine subjektive Angelegenheit. Nein, wenn Sie Zement auf meiner Nase stellen, dann würde ich gerne auch antworten. Noch eine spitze Nachfrage? Nein, hören Sie sich doch erstmal die Antwort an. Nehmen Sie die rote Nase ab. Also, es geht ja auch darum, dass man weiß, welche Ohrenstruktur, es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche Ohrenoberflächen, Ohrengewölbe, dass man einfach weiß, okay, es gibt ja auch teilweise längere Bügel, kürzere Bügel, wo neigen die sich. Manche Kundinnen und Kunden bevorzugen ja eher modische, schlanke Designs, anderen ist der Trager halt wichtiger. Haben Sie hier dafür eine Bulle auf? Da ist ja gar keine Stärke drin und Sie sind, Sie wollen mir, einem Brillenträger, sollen Sie mir... Sie können sich melden bitte, bevor Sie auf die Bühne kommen? Ja, bitte, der Herr ... Sie, ohne Dioptrien, wollen mir einem Brillenträger erklären, was Tragekomfort bedeutet? Ja, die sind ja nicht schwer oder leicht, die Gläser dadurch. Erstens, doch. Nein, zweitens, nein. Drittens, wie gesagt, ja. Viertens, nein. Und fünftens, erklären Sie mir nicht, wie Brillen funktionieren, ich arbeite da. Ja, aber mit welcher Expertise? Ich weiß seit dreiundvierzig Jahren, wie Brillen funktionieren. Ja, aber damit haben wir nichts zu tun, das ist Teil der Optiker, wir haben nur das Gestell, das Gerüst, den Rahmen. Das ist unser Job. Wir betten das medizinische Hilfsmittel ein. Wir geben ihnen einen Rahmen. Und da ist natürlich auch wichtig zu wissen, was der Tragekomfort ist, wo es wehtut. Größer, breitere Brillen, schmalere Brillen, deswegen ganz wichtig. Aber ja, Sie haben natürlich völlig recht, das ist eine absolute Farce und ich würde nie jemandem sagen, der eine Brille kaufen will. Die ist zwar hübsch, aber die trägt sich, ist einfach ein brennender Schmerz. Es ist eher so ein stechender Schmerz. Es ist ein stechender Schmerz, wohingegen bei der anderen haben wir eher, sag ich mal, so eine kratzige Oberfläche. Es ist eher, stellen Sie sich da eher eine Säge vor, wohingegen das andere eher so eine Spitzhacke ist. Genau, und das andere hier wäre eher, wir müssen sich vorstellen, wie so ein Zementblock, den man ihnen auf die Nase schnallt. Und natürlich noch dieses Modell her, das hat eher ätzende Eigenschaften, also da werden sie in kürzester Zeit einen Ausschlag an den Ohren bekommen, aber das ist ja mittlerweile ganz gut behandelbar. Also da muss man schon wissen, worum es geht, aber finde ich spannend. Ich behaupte nämlich, dass die haben wahrscheinlich, genau, 15 verschiedene Marken, die lizenziert da bei Filmen verkauft werden dürfen. Und diese Marken, da kriegen die ein paar Modelle jeden Monat rumgeschickt und die müssen nicht verkaufen.
Und wenn dann da Frau XY, die uns geschrieben hat, Tragekomforttest sind, mit ihren, bin ich eh schon skeptisch, weil sie keine schlechten Augen hat, so und dann sagt sie, ja die unangenehmen auf dem Auge, man sagt dem Kunde, ich hätte gerne diese Brille, sagt die ja nicht, nee, aber die fühlt sich an wie ätzende Flüssigkeit, die man ihr über den Schädel kippt. Aber jetzt warte mal ganz kurz. Wie ist das denn eigentlich in einem Brillenladen?
Ich habe jetzt minus zehn Dioptrien und will mir eine Brille kaufen. Ja. Jetzt nehme ich die Brille aus dem Regal und setze die auf. Welche Stärke hat diese Brille denn? Null, null. Aber dann sehe ich ja gar nicht, wie ich mit der Brille aussehe. Das ist ein Problem und bei mir ist auch noch ein großes Problem bei Sonnenbrillbrillen sehe ich ja, das ist generell aber immer bei allen Menschen ein Problem, die Sonnenbrillen anprobieren, man sieht sich mit der Sonnenbrille nur durch eine Sonnenbrille. Ja, das ist ja ein Paradoxon, ich kann ja bei den Brille ausprobieren, wenn die mit dem Spiegel vorhalten, ich sehe mich ja nicht, das heißt, die bräuchten ja eigentlich jedes Modell in jeder Stärke oder also eigentlich müsste man ja seine eigene, am besten man trägt Kontaktlinsen und trägt und setzt sich dann die Brille mit Stärke null auf und dann sieht man sich durch die Kontaktlinsen richtig. Ja, aber jetzt nur kurzsichtige Menschen sehen bis 50 cm alles gestochen scharf.
Aha!
Man weiß nicht, woher das Stechen kommt.
Du bist gestochen scharf. Aha!
Du bist gestochen scharf, wir sehen nur die Brille.
Das heißt, der Verkäufer muss dann wissen, kurzsichtig, weitsichtig.
Und ansonsten geht man 30 m weg mit einem riesigen Spiegel,
wo der andere sich in der Distanz sehen kann.
Und das Leopardenmuster nicht mehr ganz so gut rauskommen. Oder sehr nah an den Spiegel.
Ja, verstehe.
Aber man kann ja auch einfach Brillen ohne Stärke kaufen. Modisch einfach, oder? Ganz modisch, Brillen kaufen ohne Stärke. Soll ich das machen? Ja, dir würde so was stehen, finde ich. Also eine Brille würde dir stehen. Du hast gar keine Sehschwäche? Ich hatte als Kind eine Sehschwäche, aber meine Augen haben hart trainiert in der Zeit, um überhaupt was zu sehen. Deswegen haben die das korrigiert. Muskelbepackte Augen. Ich habe eine ganz schlechte Sicht und ich rieche auch nichts, also meine Sinne sind eh. Ich glaube, ich bräuchte eher eine Brille für meine Nase als für meine Augen, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich teilweise das Gefühl habe, ich rieche gar nichts. Nee, das ist, glaube ich, weil du mit deinem ganzen komischen Konsum von weirden Plötzlichkeiten, diesem Eistee und diesem Scheiss, machst du dir einfach deine ganzen Schleimhäute kaputt. Du riechst und schmeckst nichts mehr. Da kommen wir übrigens mal zu Flop 2 des Jahres 2021, nämlich euch. Euch Hörerinnen und Hörer, korrekt. Da rezenziere ich mich von. Nee nee, ich hänge mit drin. Weil ich kann mittlerweile, Entschuldigung, in diesem Podcast über nichts Tolles mehr reden. Ich bin wie Dr. Fauci jetzt im Hintergrund, wenn Trump so eine Rede hält, der im Hintergrund so steht und die Hände an die Stirn fasst. Der schönste Moment des letzten Jahres war für mich, ich habe Mr. Max entdeckt. Mr. Max mit seinem einzigartigen Claim fünf Liter ein Euro.
Fünf Liter ein Euro, no Bullshit,
fünf Liter ein Euro,
keine Kalorien,
niemand weiß, was es ist. Billiger als fucking Wasser, da steht er drauf.
Dusch dich mit dem Scheiss, es ist billiger
und wärmer. Und
dann, seitdem ich das
im Podcast erwähnt habe, und es ist wirklich
kein Witz, ausverkauft.
Jede Woche ausverkauft.
Ja.
Wo ich mir denke, einerseits denke ich mir, es kann doch nicht sein, dass genug Leute den Podcast hören, die im selben Supermarkt einkaufen wie ich und jetzt Bock auf Mr. Max haben. Auf der anderen Seite war es vom Timing so präzise, dass sich jede Woche standen da mehrere von diesen Humpen, von diesen Bottich.
Ernüstern.
Ja, Bottich da herum. Und ich habe mir jede Woche schön eine mitgenommen und seitdem ich es im Podcast erwähnt habe, auch immer ausverkauft. Was ist denn da los? Ja, das kann man mir schon vorstellen. Wahrscheinlich hat einfach dieser Kaufzwang so allgemeine Lieferschwierigkeiten ausgelöst.
Du musst jetzt gar nicht erinnern, dass dieses Domino-Steineffekt durchgezogen hat.
Schneeball-Effekt mässig.
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Klar, der fucking Pyramiden-Effekt, der zieht dir den Teppich unter den Füssen weg.
Wie eine Pyramide vorstellt.
Also da auch nochmal an der Stelle, wenn das so läuft, dann können wir das in Zukunft nicht mehr machen.
Ja, dann kann ich keine Sachen mehr vorschlagen und euch vorstellen, wenn ihr die Regale leer kauft, verdammt noch mal. Flop zwei, wir können das nicht machen. Ja, mein Flop zwei ist ja, sorry, tut mir leid, aber wie... Ich hab seitdem keinen süssen Tropfen dieses herrlichen Himmels-Nektars mehr gekostet. Diese Scheiße! Mir hat das gut getan! Diese Chemiekack hat die nicht gut getan. Das hat keine Kalorien. Das hat keinen Nachteil. Das weiss man nicht. Nicht erprobt. Nicht erprobt, was soll das denn heißen? Worthülse. Aber du kamst hier mit deinem blassen Äußeren rein. Ja, mir ging es eine Woche nicht gut, weil ich zu viel auch getrunken habe. Deine Zähne waren weich. Deine Zähne waren komplett weich. Wie so Bao.
So ein Schwamm artig.
Hast du Kennt so Bao?
What? Diese weichen
Weiss. Deine Beleidigungen
werden auch immer unnahbarer.
Deine Zähne sind weich wie Bao.
Sorry?
Mein Rap-Diss-Drag wird auch einfach
weird as fuck.
Ich habe den Kurzfilm gesehen von Disney-Pixar.
Och, schön.
Der ist süß.
Schön. Ey, die Kurzfilme, richtig toll, kann man sich noch mal reinziehen.
Ich habe gerade versucht, etwas Weichem, Weissem.
Und dann fiel mir Bao ein, als erstes.
Ja.
That's how much of a ...
Zuckerwatte vielleicht, Baumwolle, sowas in der Richtung.
Baumwolle.
Diese Schaummäuse.
Ja, ja, sowas. Beisst du den ersten Schwanz ab oder den Kopf ab, den weißen Schaummäuse? Schwanz. Ersten Schwanz? Ich auch, ne? Ersten Schwanz. So ein bisschen wie die Eidechse, die ja, und ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Gerücht ist, aber deren Schwanz ja nachwächst. Die können den abwerfen, um Feinde zu verunsichern, oder ... Sorry, Tschüss, nochmal, ich kann meinen Schwanz abwerfen? Also, Sie meinen, wie so ein Geschoss dann auf den Gegner schiessen? Ähm, nein, einfach, dass er abfällt. Danke, nächstes Tier. Sorry, ganz kurz, Entschuldigung, ja, ganz kurz, eine Sekunde noch. Aber wenn ich ... also, warum hab ich denn dann überhaupt einen Schwanz, wenn ich den einfach abwerfen kann, ohne dass es ... Ja, wenn wir dachten, halt, das ist keine Ahnung, wenn irgendwie ein Fressfeind kommt oder so was. Dann lege ich meinen Schwanz ab. Legen sie den Schwanz ab und so, und dann ist das erst mal, entweder ist es verunsichert, das Tier, oder es ist dann den Schwanz und hat erst mal genug zu fressen und sie laufen dann weiter und das wechseln. Ja, aber wenn ich ohne Schwanz leben kann, warum habe ich denn dann überhaupt einen? Ja, um Feind zu verwirren, sie haben so einen One-Shot-Freifahrtschein. Das ist wie, kennen Sie Herr der Ringe, wo man halt, Frodo gibt man ja dann so ein paar Sachen. Und da hat er zum Beispiel einmal diesen hellen, das Licht von Dings. Ja, das habe ich nicht verstanden, dieses Flüssig-Ding. Weil, ist es aufgebraucht, wenn es einmal leuchtet? Ja, genau. Das wird aber nicht gesagt, weder im Film noch im Buch. Also, ich glaube, das wird, nein, aber kann ich denn nicht dann statt dem Schwanz einfach so eine Art Giftstachel haben? Weil wenn das eh egal ist, ob ich den habe oder nicht, dann gib mir doch einfach einen Giftstachel. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass das, das ist nur der Grund, dass es durchgegangen ist, liegt an so ein paar Sachen, die da gingen, irgendwie zwischen Gott und diesem Engel. Ich glaube, die hatten was und sie hatte nur schlechte Ideen und irgendwie ist es auch nicht so durchgekommen und dann ist diese Schwanzidee durchgekommen. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht, also es war nicht meine Idee. Also wenn es nach mir ging, hätten sie irgendwie Giftzähne oder so. Ja, ja, geil, irgend so was. Aber es ist halt, Entschuldigung, aber jetzt einfach den Schwanz ablegen, also zumindest ein bisschen schießen oder dass der Schwanz giftig ist und wenn die dann den fressen, dann sterben die oder irgendein. Das ist nicht giftig, es ist lecker, sogar sehr lecker. Auch in Delikatesse, in vielen Ländern eine Delikatesse. Ja, aber Leute, das ist doch wirklich Bullshit. Nächstes Tier. Hallo, ich bin der Igel. Kann ich auch Blätter aufspiessen auf meinen Torn? Nein, alles aufspiessen, außer Dinge, die dich tarnen. Nächstes Tier. Oh, man fährt da so einen leckeren Schwanz. Moment, ich kenne Sie doch aus dieser Serie. Ja? Ich kenne Sie doch aus dieser Reality-Show. Nach der Folge hat mich meine Frau verlassen, das haben die nicht mehr reingeschnitten. Oh Gott, warum? Ja, die wollten, die haben das alles mitgefilmt, jeden Streit, aber nichts davon kam in die Folge rein. Warum nichts? Das erste Mal die reich schneiden. Ja, habe ich mir auch gedacht, aber die haben dann gemeint, dass sie sich eher auf den Immobilienteil konzentrieren wollen. Oh, hat auch ein sehr seriöses Reality-Format. Ja, jetzt bin ich in einer neuen Sendung mit Dates. Die Dates suche eine neue Frau, ja. Eagle-Dating? Ja, die hatten keine Igel mehr. Igel und was jetzt noch? Ja, jetzt so eine Flamingo-Frau, die ist aufregend. Wie ist denn das mit Nähe und Igeln eigentlich? Tut Nähe nicht weh? Igel tun sich notorisch schwer mit Nähe, ja, das stimmt. Naja, ich weiß nicht, was Ernstes wird. Tschüss! Ciao, ciao, viel Erfolg. Gott, oh Gott. Gott, oh Gott. Die dürfen sich nicht zu nahe kommen. Ein Callback zur letzten Folge übrigens. Immer Spaß. Fußnote, Callback zur letzten Folge. Ihr müsst die letzte Folge noch mal reinhören. Wir bauen Brücken. Aber es ist immer Spaß. Nach hinten. Es macht immer Spaß, Sachen den Kopf abzubeissen. Das ist auch wirklich so, Weihnachtsmann einfach schön. Deswegen finde ich auch den, bin ich gar nicht so sehr bei Weihnachtsmännern, sondern eher Weihnachtshase. Osterhasen. Alles durcheinander. Das meine ich. Du warst mal fitter im Kopf. Aber seitdem du Mr. Max so eine Aussage. Nee, seitdem du diesen Scheiß trinkst. Du warst auch echt mal fitter im Kopf. Ja, seitdem du diesen Scheiß trinkst. Du hast ja völlig recht. Seitdem du diesen fünf Liter einen Euro Scheiß trinkst, glaube ich, wirst du langsam ein bisschen dusselig. Ja, aber das stimmt nicht, weil ich habe es ja lange nicht mehr getrunken. Also eigentlich müsste ich wieder aufgebaut werden. Das ist halt so das Ding, wenn du einmal abhängig bist, dann baut dein Körper ab. Nee, aber deswegen bin ich, was Weihnachten eher angeht, eher bei Dominostein und Ostern dann eher der Osterhase, weil es macht einfach Spaß, erst in die Löffel reinzubeissen, ihn leiden zu lassen, er hört nichts mehr, er hört die Hilfeschreie seiner Familie nicht, Hilfe, da bist dich gerade jemand, und ich beiße ihm die Ohren weg, damit er das nicht hören kann, und dann weiss ich den Hinterkopf ab und dann vorne rein. Dominostein ist komplett falsch, der Name, ne, für das weihnachtliche Gebäck. Ja, also komplett falsch. Da hat man sich komplett vertan. Dominostein, auf welcher Ebene ist es? Punkt eins ist ein Würfel. Punkt eins ist ein klarer Würfel. Punkt zwei, alles was man mit Dominostein assoziiert, hat da keine Bewandtnis. Man kann ihn nicht in Reihe schalten, man kann ihn nicht übereinander schalten, nichts davon. Dominos verbinde ich entweder mit den Umkipp, äh, Ketten, wie heißt das nochmal? Domino-Effekt, Kettenreaktion, ja, oder halt mit den Punkten im Spiel, im Ablegespiel. Richtig. Das ist nicht zum Beinem, beides nicht. Beides nicht. Beides nicht. Es ist sogar im Gegenteil innen noch gefüllt, mit so einer fruchtartigen Gannertmasse, gannertartiger Masse. Von daher bin ich Thema verfehlt, Dominostein falsch. Vor allem, ich weiß zeitlich jetzt ein bisschen falsch, aber es gibt ja dann teilweise zur Weihnachtszeit, zur guten Weihnachtszeit, die wir alle genossen haben, ja auch schön beim Bäcker die Dominosteine. Ich rede jetzt nicht von der Packung, der Plastikpackung von Aldi, sondern von die beim Bäcker, die nochmal nämlich richtig grösser sind. Die nochmal so grösser sind wie fünf, sechs Dominosteine. Das Wort Bäcker. Bäcker. Ja, Bäcker ist toll. Backen. Schön der Bäcker Hessbacher. Finde ich richtig gut. Backen. Backen ist einfach ein tolles Wort. Genau wie Buch. Ich bin ein richtiger Bücherwurm. Schön Buch durchlesen. Ich glaube, alles, was diese sagt man gern. Ich mag ja auch diese Zeit, in der Kinder Buchstaben wie die Aussprache sagen. Die sagen nicht B, sondern die sagen B. Das ist auch so eine ganz spezielle Zeit im Leben eines jeden Menschen, wo man so Buchstaben benennt. Danach nie wieder, da sagt man B, K, aber da sagt man K. Ich bin Karolin mit K. Einfach denkst du, ja, in zwei Monaten wirst du es anders sagen. Mit dein dummes Maul. Ich bin Valentina mit W. So. W. Und wo ist W näher dran? W. Als W. Beides nicht das, was man sagt. Das ist ja nicht Valentiner. Ich bin Valentin mit F. Oder W, je nachdem, in welchem Kontext. Ja, aber es gibt so eine spezielle Zeit. Danach nie wieder. Das ist also diese goldene Zeit. Genießt das, wenn ihr ein Kind seid, genießt diese magischen drei Monate. Wie lange ist die Zeit? Ich glaube länger. Stoppt das gerne mal ab, liebe Eltern, stoppt das gerne mal ab mit einer Stoppuhr. Ich sag dir, Jährchen. Das ist ein Jährchen. Und das war jetzt nämlich die I-Männchen-Jährchen-Phase. Mit I. Diese Ö-Phase ist nämlich die erste Jahr auf der Grundschule-Phase. Ein Jahr, glaube ich. Aber was sagen, Flop drei? Ne, Top drei, letztes Jahr, die Zahl drei. Ich finde, die Zahl drei hat wieder richtig delivered. Zum Beispiel letztens, ich habe einen Schneemann gesehen und dachte mir, meine Herren, wie perfekt ist die Anzahl drei Kugeln für einen Schneemann? Und zwei wären zu wenig, vier wären zu viel, drei ist perfekt. Und die Zahl drei zieht sich beim Schneemann komplett durch. Du hast drei Kugeln, drei Knöpfe und drei Baumaterialien. Schnee, Knöpfe, Möhre. Ja, vergiss den Zylinder nicht, den heute nicht mehr viele Leute haben. Deswegen jetzt so eine Garfield Basecap. So was in der Richtung. Das ist eine New York Yankees. Ja, kann auch sein. Ja, oder halt heute Ironman. Ja, oder diese Kacke. Nee, aber ich habe auch nicht mehr so viele Schneemänner gesehen. Ich habe auch keinen Schnee gesehen dieses Jahr, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Letztes Jahr habe ich nicht gesehen. Wo war Schnee? Nirgendwo. Wo war er? Wo war er? Alle in einem Ort in Niederbrück kam der gesamte Schnee runter. Tausend Tonnen Schnee pro Meter. Tausend Kilo, ne? Das ist das Grösste, was dir eingefallen ist. Ja, tausend Kilo. Das ist eine Menge. Das ist wirklich viel. Das ist wirklich viel, muss man sagen. So, dann habe ich erschreckende Neuigkeiten bekommen. Heute ist ein bisschen, ne, ihr seht schon dieses Jahr. Klapper-TJahr. Nämlich habe ich eine ganz, ganz interessante Nachricht bekommen von Tom, denn ich war ja ein Rule Breaker. Ich war ja ein kleiner Regelbrecher, bin ja in die Achterbahn gegangen, obwohl ich viel zu groß bin als die Achterbahn. So wird Tom geschrieben und wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob ich den Namen sagen soll. Kannst du nochmal, liegt in deinem Ermessen, ob du den jetzt gepiept hast oder nicht. Tom schreibt. Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom, Tom. Einfach auch um dir ein bisschen. Es gibt auch mehr, wir wissen noch nicht Tom, Thomas, Tomatheos. Hi Stefan. Kleiner Achterbahn-Nachtrag zur vorletzten Folge Mikronesien. Auch hier vielen Dank. Schönen Titel benannt. Mensch, Tom ist super.
Ihr seid alle so Streber.
Ich arbeite für MacRides,
welche Achterbahn unter anderem den Concord Coaster im Europapark herstellt.
Also, er arbeitet wirklich für eine Achterbahnfirma.
Wir könnten hier nicht lächerlich
überqualifiziert sein für jemanden,
der eine Antwort gibt an den Podcast-Sufo.
Deine Sorge, skalpiert zu werden,
war unbegründet, aber doch ... Das ist doch mal ein Satz, den man gerne liest, oder? Ein richtiger Wohlfühl-Satz. Für mich geht man von meinem Arzt her. Deine Sorge, skalpiert zu werden, war unbegründet, aber es geht bergab mit dem Satz, aber doch auch wiederum begründet. Oh, okay. Es ist eine Achterbahnfahrt, diese Nachricht. Das liegt ihm im Blut einfach. Der Satz von Achterbahnfahrt. Alter, und jetzt wird es fachchinesisch. Zu jeder Achterbahnfahrt wird nämlich ein sogenanntes Lichtraumprofil erstellt. Ach, was kann er damit meinen? Wir verstehen nichts. Das Profil gibt den Bereich an, mit dem der Passagier seine Arme und Füsse erreichen kann. In diesem Bereich dürfen keine Stützenschienen etc. stehen. Deswegen kann man meistens unbekümmert die Arme in der Achterbahn hochreissen, hochreissen auch, ne, auch geiles Wort, aber stimmt, ohne dass was passiert oder sogar das Gefühl geniessen, dass die Arme abfliegen. Ist das das, was man damit erreicht? Darum geht's bei Achterbahn? Ich bin immer falsch, Achterbahn gefahren, es geht um das Gefühl, dass die Arme abreisten. Ich glaube, Tom ist falsch, Achterbahn gefahren.
Aber er arbeitet für Achterbahn.
Er kennt sich aus.
In deinem Fall warst du aber grösser als die Vorgaben,
so dass auch deine Gliedmassen das Lichtraumprofil überschreiten hättest können.
Also ein Kopf kleiner wird man selten, aber eine gebrochenen Hand kann schon mal vorkommen.
Punkt Smile.
Punkt Swinkel Smile. Du stellst dir das mal vor. Brichst dir einfach die Hand kann schon mal vorkommen. Punkt, smiley. Punkt, swinker smiley.
Stell dir das mal vor!
Brichst dir einfach die Hand mitten in der Fahrt.
Aber das wird auch, ehrlich gesagt, best case scenario.
Denn wenn was passiert, eine gebrochene Hand, ist doch scheißegal.
Ja, aber den Rest des Tages ...
Ich dachte, zerschmettert, dachte ich.
Wenn du damit wie viel tausend kmh durch einen Pfeiler fährst ...
Ja, und deine Schlabberärmchen, die geben ja auch sofort nach. Nein. So einen bösen Blick hat die selten kassiert. Die können Schlabberärmchen. Aber das ist ja verrückt, weil die stellen diese Achterbahnen her. Wie oft wird denn da eine solche Achterbahn verkauft? Doch nur ein einziges Mal, oder? Nur einmal an einen Europapark.
Da gibt es dann diese Achterbahnen.
Oder verkaufen die dann 20 an, dann gibt es die, dann steht die auch noch mal so in Ungarn
und so in China und was, oder?
Meistens nicht baugleich, meistens ja ans Terrain
angepasst, aber
ich würde jetzt mal behaupten,
dass es
Reihen gibt, also verschiedene Coaster
mit verschiedenen, also die Schienen sind
gleich, nicht der Streckenverlauf,
aber die Bauweise der Schienen
Vielen Dank. dass es Reihen gibt, also verschiedene Coaster mit verschiedenen, also die Schienen sind gleich, nicht der Streckenverlauf, aber die Bauweise der Schienen oder mal der Zug ist der gleiche oder die Station und dann passt man das dem verschiedenen Terrain an. Okay, gut, alles klar, Terrain haben wir das auch geklärt. Viele Grüße von einem treuen Zuhörer, Tom. Und jetzt, was ich geil finde, weil wir sind ja auch in den Achterbahn-Themenpark-Podcast, PS, das nächste Franchise steht schon in den Startlöchern. Was wird es sein? Okay, jetzt müssen wir aber die Prognose geben, die das Podcast-UFO-Prognose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Hose-Wars-Achterbahn, wir alle kennen die Indiana-Jones-Wasserbahn, wir kennen alle die Flucht der Grebik-Wasserbahn. Was kommt als nächstes? Was ist the next big shit? Und wir alle kennen den Avatar-Freizeitpark. Ja, in dem es keine Avatare gibt, diese blauen Navi-Wesen, gibt es nicht in dem Avatar-Park. Auch hier noch mal einen Shoutout an Jenny Nicholson, eh die lustigste Person der ganzen Welt. Ja, großer Shoutout noch mal an der Stelle. Falls ihr euch für Achterbahnen und Freizeitparks interessiert, Jenny Nicholson ist eure Anlaufstelle auf YouTube. Was ist das große Franchise? Wir haben ja schon, hießen die noch mal Arthur und die Minimis oder so was? Minimois. Minimois. Ich sag mal, der Europa-Park hat ja ein sehr spezielles, ja, Franchisetum. Also da sind die Dinge, die da, naja. Die Dinge, die da gefeatured werden, sind jetzt sagen wir mal eher sehr nischig, und zwar alle in derselben Nische, nämlich Luc Besson. Also sowohl Valyrian als auch Atom die Minimois sind quasi Luc Besson-Filme, und die werden da gefeatured. Es gibt auch noch andere Franchises. Nee, eigentlich nur, es gibt noch diese Silver Star, das ist einfach eine Mercedes-Achterbahn und Blue Something, Blue Fire ist eine Gazprom-Achterbahn, die von Nord Stream 2 gesponsert wurde, muss man auch ehrlich mal so sagen. Ich überlege. Aber alle anderen, es ist sonst kein Franchise. Also das andere Franchise wären dann eher Städte Europas oder so, oder Länder Europas. Aber es ist sonst kein Freizeitpark, der jetzt auf die großen Brands Wert legt. Und da wäre natürlich für uns jetzt spannend zu sagen, was wären coole, nur Luc-Besson-Filme. Es ist natürlich super schwierig, weil du willst natürlich vor allem Kinder kriegen, aber Kinder sind ja heute gar nicht mehr so tief drin in Filmeserien, die sind ja dann eher TikTok Gaming, also natürlich sowas wie eine Fortnite-Achterbahn, könnte man sich gut vorstellen. Oder diese Hotten Boys aus dem Elevator. Genau. Okay, ich lege mich fest. Und zwar ist ein Freefall Tower. Die Elevator Boys Achterbahn, das ist eine geile Idee. Finde ich geil, und zwar ist es ein Freefall Tower, der aussieht wie ein grosser Elevator. Und wenn man Glück hat, erreicht man dann dieses Showszenario, wo man die alle Schaltlässe mal sieht. Genau, und die sind alle drin. Und jeder Freizeitpark braucht dann fünf hotte Guys, die Models, die dann einfach da immer drinstehen, um mit in den Fotos zu machen. Das ist eigentlich ideal. Ich glaube, Achterbahnen heutzutage müssen auch den Instagram-Hunger stillen, dass du halt geile Fotos machst irgendwie. Das ist schon nicht dumm. Vielleicht deswegen ja, so was wie Instagram, TikTok, Fortnite in der Richtung, dass du da Fotos machst oder halt wirklich auch nochmal Bärenmarke, dass du wirklich den Bärenmarke-Bär nochmal rausholst und so eine Art Alpenachterbahn irgendwie so schön mit so einem Wasserfall, schön mit so einer Enzianwiese oder sowas in der Richtung, fände ich auch gut. Ich überlege gerade, was wäre ein Squid Game, wäre vielleicht nicht so schlecht. Ja, aber für Kinder halt nicht. Ich glaube, du musst bei Franchises immer auf Kinder gehen, dann halt eher sowas wie Ferdi Fuchs oder Fred Ferkel. Fred Ferkel könnte ich mir richtig gut vorstellen. Oder Colorado, was für eine ultra strange Welt ist, Colorado. Colorado der Film, das ist doch auch mal geil, oder? Haribo Colorado der Film, wo sie alle denken, was passiert in diesem Film? Jeder würde sich zumindest den Trailer angucken, weil man sich einfach fragt, das in 90 Minuten? Viel Spaß. Ich finde das super. Ich finde gerade so die weirdesten Sachen, so einen Film zu machen, finde ich super, weil ich glaube, das würde die Leute ins Kino bringen. Aber ganz kurz, das wäre schon ein Viral-Hit. Du bist ja Autor, du kennst dich ja aus. Es gibt doch bestimmt Autoren, die Ideen ausformulieren sollen, oder? Also deren Aufgabe es ist, die kriegen eine Idee, so hey, wir haben folgende Filmidee, das ist aber nur eine ganz grobe Idee, hättest du nicht Bock, da mal einen ersten Entwurf zu schreiben? Ja, lustigerweise habe ich das auch bekommen in der Anfrage. Ja? Ich darf nicht sagen, welches Franchise, ich glaube, ich darf gar nichts sagen, aber ich habe auch diese Frage bekommen, ob ich nicht mal einen ersten Entwurf schreiben möchte von diesem diesem alten deutschen Franchise. Und es ist halt ... so ein Kinderbuch, was man kennt. Oh, der tapfere Schneiderlein? Darf ich nicht sagen. Aber es ist sehr lustig, und ich dachte mir eigentlich mehr ... Kennst du noch Gretel, sowas? Weniger ... Es bildet sich weniger an. Es ist eine Hauptfigur. Es gibt keine Geschichte. Es gibt keine Geschichte. Keine Geschichte? Es ist halt so ein alter Klassiker. Und man denkt, das ist halt die Geschichte. Und ich war so intrigued, das zu machen, einfach aus Scheiss. Aber hab dann abgesagt. Ich hab überlegt, ob man nicht als Prank mal irgendwie ein paar hundert Euro in die Hand nimmt und wirklich mal so einem Autoren sagt, schreib uns mal meinen ersten Draft zu Colorado, der Film. Und einfach mal gucken, was passiert, und wir lesen das Skript vor.
Wollen wir das machen?
Und zwar nicht für, ich würde erstmal on hold, Colorado, der Film sagen, aber wir können ja nochmal was anderes überlegen. Aber ich finde halt sowas gut, wo man halt nichts naheliegendes, wenn es das Bärenmarke der Film, das ist ein Bär, der verliert seine Familie und muss dann in der Molkerei, wird dann angestellt, Praktikum und dann sind die Milchpreise zu niedrig und dann geht er da irgendwie, macht einen Protest und alle Waldtiere versammeln sich und so weiter. Genau. Da hast du eine Geschichte im Kopf. Mal sofort was im Kopf. Bei Colorado? Also ist die Himbeer der Star? Ist das Lacritz-Sandwich, der hat die Figur, Hauptfigur, was passiert da? Ich finde auch gut, wenn wir sagen, das ist kein animierter Film. Weil jetzt habe ich noch viel mehr Fragezeichen im Kopf. Wenn nämlich diese scheiß Figuren nicht sprechen können. Drama, ja. Wer ist dann die Hauptfigur? Aber einfach mal gucken, was jemand daraus macht, der Geld dafür bekommt. Was da passiert, fände ich mal eine gute Idee, das zu machen. Einmal zu schauen aus so Bullshit-Ideen, so KitKat der Film. Einfach, KitKat wünscht sich als Marketingkampagne einen Film, Netflix-Film, Netflix hat zugesagt, auch da sind Millionen geflossen, wir brauchen jetzt halt einfach nur eine Story, irgendwas halt, was zu KitKat passt. Schreib da mal was. und dann halt so okay was ich geil finde der so kinder schoko fresh oh ja so
der film die jetzt auch was es nicht leichter macht, keine Nilpferde mehr sind. Stimmt, aber was sind die denn mittlerweile? Formen, geometrische Formen, also another curveball, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich weiß auch nicht, wie man darüber jetzt regeln will. Ich finde es aber auch krass, dass dieses Haribo-Männchen zu wenig bekannt ist, oder?
Du meinst den Goldbeeren?
Nee, nee, nee, diesen Jungen mit den schwarzen Haaren.
Nee, nee, nee, not a thing.
Doch, klar, natürlich.
Gibt's nicht.
Mandela-Effekt.
Haribo-Effekt.
Wie gibt's nicht?
Nee, gibt's nicht.
Es gibt doch ein Haribo-Männchen.
Ich weiß, sehr viele Leute behaupten, dass der Haribo-Junge 1994 in einem Gefängnis gestorben ist. Aber eigentlich gibt es nur den Goldbeeren. Aber denke ich jetzt an den Pringles? Auch Mandela-Effekt, Haribo schreibt man mit zwei R. Nie gesehen. Playmobil-Männchen. Den meine ich, diesen Jungen mit den schwarzen Haaren, den gibt es, von wegen Mandela-Effekt hier. Gut, dann war der Mandela-Effekt, dass man nicht den Kind nicht ... Entschuldigung, Schlaganfall. Naja, ich finde die Idee ganz, ganz klasse. Ich finde die Idee super, vor allem es ist ja auch nicht weit weg. Also du hast ja bei ... kenne ich nicht. Ja doch, den kenne ich. Als das Logo kenne ich den so wohl, mit den viel zu grossen Hosen. Mit roter Hose, schwarzer Haare. Ja, so kenne ich den, ehrlich gesagt. Der hat nicht mal einen Namen, oder? Aber hier, diese Mercedes-Achterbahn-Lorentin ist ja das Gleiche. Na gut, eine Achterbahn ist natürlich leichter darzustellen als jetzt ein 90-Minute-Fiel. Ich habe andere, finde ich, ja, na klar, aber ich habe natürlich andere Anforderungen an eine Achterbahn. Eine Achterbahn muss auch ein bisschen Storytelling, Theming haben. Und Mercedes ist es auch eher ein sperriges Thema. Ja, schwierig. Sperriges Franchise. Hat kein gutes Maskottchen, so Sterni. Ein Stern. Dieses Mercedes-Stern. Und die Achterbahn heißt Silvers da. Also man merkt, die wurde schon, da wurde die Kreativität schon gemolken. Das stimmt schon, ja. Ne, aber sowas fände ich natürlich gut, wenn man sagt, Schoko Fresh und jetzt ist es auch kein Nilfett mehr. Da will ich immer jetzt in Autoren sehen, wie da die grauen Zellen angestrengt werden. Lass uns mal machen. Ich überleg grad ein Pen and Paper, wo alle so diese Maskottchen spielen, die dann so Fähigkeiten haben, basierend auf den Süßigkeiten, für die sie stehen. So der Pringles-Typ ist halt super reich. Nee, der Monopoly-Mann ist reich. Sorry, ist es derselbe, der Pringles-Mann und der Monopoly-Mann? Nein. Doch, das ist der selbe, wenn du derselbe wärst. Ehrlich gesagt. Aber so, der Monopoly-Mann ist halt wahnsinnig reich. Und der Spefuchs ist ultrageizig. Clever, sehr schlatsam, aber sehr geizig. Der hat sehr viel Geld, aber er ist nicht bereit, das auszugeben. Den will ich mal sehen, so von Nils Bohm aufgespielt, würde ich gerne den Spähfuchs sehen. Das ist eine Frage markenrechtlich, aber die würden sich wahrscheinlich eher freuen. Es sei denn, die werden jetzt irgendwie als weirde Verbrecher dargestellt. Ich wollte gerade sagen, entweder wird es das teuerste Pen and Paper, was Rocket Beans GmbH jemals gemacht hat, weil so waren nicht viele Lizenzstreits, mit Anwälten draufzukommen, oder es wird das Billigste, mit dem sie am meisten einnehmen, weil man alles irgendwie verkaufen kann. Aber man müsste das dann machen. Es gibt so eine riesige Welt mit so Unterwelten, jeweils so diese, ja Kantone könnte man sagen, in denen jeweils die so der Chef sind. Also es gibt die Pringles-Welt, dann gibt es die Bärenmarke-Welt, dann gibt es die Ferdie-Fuchs-Wuchs Welt und irgendwie gerät dieses gesamte Kantongefüge in Gefahr. Es gibt irgendeinen Bösewicht, der greift an und als erstes fällt das Ferdi-Fuchs-Land. Und der Bösewicht hat Ferdi-Fuchs entführt und jetzt werden zu so einem Zentralrat der Maskottchen aus allen Bereichen der Welt werden die Maskottchen zusammengerufen und man sagt, wir müssen es aufhalten. Und viele sagen, Toucan Sam sagt, fickt euch mir egal, in meinem Dschungel bin ich sicher, haut ab. Der Charming Bear sagt auch, nö, nö, nö, ich bleib erst mal zu Hause. Ich hab schon viele Probleme, kommen und gehen, sehen. Ich brauche jetzt nicht das Nächste. Das wird vorbeiziehen, die Krise wird vorübergehen.
Der haut ab und alle verlassen diese Konferenz, außer natürlich unsere vier Helden, die am Ende in einem riesigen Raum sitzen und sich zusammenfinden und sagen, wir müssen was machen. Wir, der weirde Haribo-Junge, der weirde Kinderriegel-Junge, der Zwieback-Brand-Junge, fünf Menschenkinder, die wild alt geworden sind, also alle ein bisschen zu Kinderstarmäßig verkommen, so Wohlstandsverwahrlosung. Und der Produzent sitzt da, Moment mal, ihr konntet aus allen Maskottchen wählen und ihr entscheidet euch für vier Jungen? Das ist es geworden, euer Konzept? Ja, am Ende ist es so halt so wie die Knickerbocker-Bande einfach geworden. Am Ende ist es TKKG geworden. So viel verspielt, so viel Potenzial am Ende ist J, J, J, J, Junge, Junge, Junge, Junge geworden. Das ist so boring. Das wäre eine gute Idee Idee, ja. Das war nicht schlecht. Oder ich glaube, was ich spielen würde, ist das Lacoste-Krokodil. Oh! Das glaube ich, würde ich spielen. Ein gewieftes, kleines Krokodil. Ja, wahnsinnig stilvoll, hat Stil, edel, hat immer die besten Kleidungen an, aber auch bescheiden. Ich würde den NBC-Peacock, den V von NBC, bisschen flamboyant, aber auch natürlich hat immer, und da würde ich dich fragen als Spielleiter, ob nicht verschiedene Serien und Filme quasi auf dem Federkleid. Stefan, nein, das haben wir schon, du kannst nicht die Gerechtigkeiten von allen NBC-Serien haben, das wäre overpowered.
Ich meine, Etienne spielt den Ralf-Laurenen-Polospieler, der hat ein Pferd, mehr nicht. Das ist halt auch nicht so viel drin.
Aber eigentlich eine geile Welt, ich glaube, das mache ich.
Ich spiele den Peugeot Puma, den Puma Puma, Peugeot Puma.
Moment, ich spiele den Nike-Schmusch.
Ich spiele den Jaguar, Jaguar, mit vier Wildkatzen. Moment, der Peugeot, Jaguar? Nee, der Peugeot hat ja auch eine Form, eine Wildkatze. Weiß ich nicht welche. Weiß ich nicht welche. Löwe vielleicht. Jaguar hat einen Jaguar, Puma hat einen Puma. Okay. Das hat das Potenzial, extrem boring zu werden. Es wird auch sehr abstrakt, weil wenn jemand den Nike Swoosh spielt, wird es halt schon schwierig zu erklären, was da jetzt genau passiert, wie die sich fortbewegen. Ist Nike nicht eine Göttin des Kampfes? Sehr gut. Ja, ist sie sehr gut. Also Captain Fantastic wurde das zumindest erwähnt. Toller Film, kann man sich auch mal angucken. Schaut euch gerne mal Serien und Filme an, bitte. Die müssen weggeglotzt werden, die stopfen das ganze Internet voll, die Server, überall in den Leitungen hängen diese Serien und Filme, die müsst ihr weggucken. Jetzt so zwischen den Jahren gucke ich gerne wieder Trash und habe mir überlegt, ich fange wieder einmal mit Staffel vier, wieder einmal mit Supernatural an. Oh, schön, warum genau fängst du mit Staffel vier an? Da wird es nämlich cool, da kommen die Engel. Wie mag ich es da? Da wird's mythologisch spannend. Ich glaube, da sind wir sehr verfeindet, weil ich bin ja eher Team Vampire Diaries. Ich hab das Gefühl, Supernatural-Fans und Vampire Diaries-Fans können nicht gut miteinander. Wie P.D. meinst du? Vampire Diaries. Lieb ich ja, die Serie. Ich hab viel drüber gehört, auch von unserer Lieben, wie liebes Freundin Jenny Nicholson, die ganz toll das zusammengefasst hat.
Ich glaube, ich weiß jetzt mehr über Vampire Diaries,
als ich jemals hätte
gedacht hätte zu wissen. Aber super sympathische
Serie, wie sie das beschreibt, so dass die Autoren
sich mit jeder Staffel konsequent in die
Ecke schreiben, völlig bewusst,
um dann sich irgendwie da rauszuwiesen.
Um immer mehr Regeln zu brechen und Dinge zu vergessen.
Und da dachte ich mir,
weil natürlich im Writers' Room sitzt man dann ab und zu und denkt, wie kommen wir denn aus diesem Schlamassel hier wieder raus, was wir uns da eingebrockt haben und teilweise schon angedreht haben. Wie kommen wir da wieder raus? Und was uns nie in den Sinn gekommen ist, ist einfach unter den Teppich zu kehren. Man hat immer, und ich glaube, das ist gar nichts Schlechtes, weil bei Vampir-Serien auch gerade so, man glaubt einfach sehr viel
und man kann einfach, man kommt mit sehr viel durch
und aber dann teilweise einfach
etwas einzuführen, wie es da gab es
irgendwie so ein Artefakt, so ein Kompass,
der zeigt, wo Vampire sind,
was dann irgendwann so lächerlich stark wurde
und die Autoren zur Verzweiflung gebracht
hatte, weil es so einfach, dass so viele
Probleme lösen würde und dann haben die einfach
das rausgeschrieben und es wurde
nicht mehr zerstört, es wurde einfach nicht mehr
Vielen Dank. und die Autoren zur Verzweiflung gebracht hatte. Weil es so einfach, dass es so viele Probleme lösen würde,
und dann haben die einfach das rausgeschrieben,
und es wurde nicht mehr zerstört, es wurde einfach nicht mehr erwähnt.
Du hast ja die Macht. Anders als zum Beispiel in der Pen-and-Paper-Runde,
wo die Spieler immer sagen, wir setzen sofort unser Vampir-Artefakt ein,
und du als Leiter immer so, das ist aber kein normaler Vampir,
das ist halb Vampir, halb Mumie, und da geht es nicht und so. In Serien kann es einfach bestimmt, die vergessen es einfach, die setzen einfach nie wieder ein, Harry Potter auch Teil drei, Zeitreise, einfach nie wieder eingesetzt, unhinterfragt, niemand fragt, das hätte ich eigentlich geil gefunden, wenn in Film sechs nochmal Dobby fragt, so, haben wir nicht diese Zeitreisemaschine und Hermine so, Egal, egal, wenn das, das wird halbend. Egal, so, also, wir brauchen... Und dann Dobby ist tot, nein, Dobby ist tot.
Ah, schade, immer diese Knollkrankheiten oder Kobold.
Elf, elf, Haus elf.
Was auch immer, sorry.
Puh, weiter geht's, Horcrux-Jagd.
Horcruxe, ich habe auch jetzt wieder, bei Weihnachten läuft immer Harry Potter im Fernsehen. Und das ist ein bisschen so, wie wenn ich dann bei YouTube mal über so eine Mathe-Vorlesung stolper, mir die angucke und dann denke, ich komme schon wieder rein, ich verstehe schon was. Genauso ist für mich Harry Potter und die letzten Teile zu gucken, weil ich mich immer wieder dabei erwische, wie ich dann google, wieso zum Teufel Harry Potter überlebt hat.
Ja, ich glaube, ich könnte diese Harry Potter Reihe schauen und die letzten drei Filme in anderer Reihenfolge sehen und mir würde es nicht mal auffallen. Mir würde es auch nicht auffallen.
Ich würde nicht mal hinterfragen, weil ich einfach so lost bin in dem Teil mit verschiedenen Leuten und dann dupliziert sich das und Tom Riddle und Mr. Swigglebirth und Campbell Batch und so, keine Ahnung, völlig raus. Ich würde das nicht hinterfragen, null. Ja, aber Vampire Diaries klang ganz toll und ich dachte mir auch, da muss man wieder hinkommen, mal so eine Serie zu gucken, die auch mal einfach so einen Quatsch macht. Ja, ist die Frage, wie guckt man Ser? Guckt man sie wirklich in Westen oder auch mal teilweise auch so eine Popkultur-Meta-Perspektive, wo man dann vielleicht ab und zu mal sagt, ja, schon auch irgendwie sehr lustig, dass jetzt passiert. Nicht, wie kommen die Figuren da wieder raus, wie kommen die Autoren da wieder raus. Und bei Supernatural ist es auch an sehr vielen Ecken so, dass am Anfang jetzt, wenn ich dann so eine, bei der Staffel, wo dann die Engel zum ersten Mal auftauchen und alle Dämonen hauen ab, die Dämonen waren drei Staffeln lang die krassesten Gegner, die die hatten, unbesiegbar und die haben teilweise eine ganze Staffel gebracht, um einen Dämon umzubringen und dann kommt Staffel vier, fängt an, ein Engel erscheint und alle Dämonen fliehen und sagen, wir können hier nicht werden, Engel sind das Krasseste, ich habe seit 2000 Jahren keine Engel gesehen, holy shit, wir müssen hier weg, es gibt nichts Mächtigeres als das, und man denkt so, aber die Engel sind die Guten, und jetzt habt ihr einen Engel auf eurer Seite, und man denkt auch, man hört so die Hirne brutzeln im Weiterschwum, weil man denkt, wie kommen die denn da jetzt wieder raus und dann, ah okay, das erste Siegel der Apokalypse wurde gebrochen und dann, ah okay, wer kommt am Ende dann da raus, wenn alle Siegel gebrochen werden, Lucifer, man denkt, ah gut, wir haben es doch, gut, aber jetzt schraubt sich die Serie auch mythologisch gerade in ungeahnte Höhen, wir hatten vorher Dämonen, Easy, Werwölfefe, Vampire. So, jetzt haben wir den ersten Engel. Jetzt wird schon von Lucifer gesprochen. Here we fucking go. Es wurde schon die Frage gestellt, gibt es einen Gott? Und der Engel sagt, ja, es gibt fucking einen Gott. Geil, weil kommt Gott. Kommt Gott, aber dann gibt es auch noch Poseidon, der doch mächtiger ist als Gott. Und Zeus darüber und dann die Titanen. Ja, und irgendwann muss er jetzt Weltreligionen in einer Mächtigkeitsliste Ja, genau. Wo ist Buddha? Wo steht Buddha? Wo steht Buddha? Ja, das ist wirklich schwierig. Ja, und da wird es auch irgendwann schwierig. Ja, so wie bei Fluch der Karibik, wo irgendwann in Teil 9 oder so die anfangen, wir müssen jetzt Poseidons Dreizack finden. Sorry, was? Poseidon existiert in dieser Welt und der hat, und das ist ein Okay,, okay. Nee, wieso? Du bist denn jetzt da so. In Teil drei ist Kalypso die Götter des Lebens. Ja, da ist auch schon völlig lost. Teil drei ist auch schon völlig lost. Nee, zähl ich immer noch zu den richtigen Guten. Nein, nee, die Diskussion möchte ich im Keim ersticken, und zwar indem ich euch ein wunderschönes neues Jahr wünsche. Frohes neues Jahr, haut rein, wir wünschen euch viel viel Spaß und hoffen, dass ihr uns dieses Jahr wieder mit begleitet, wir hatten ein tolles Jahr, letztes Jahr, es wird wieder viel auf euch zukommen, wir freuen uns, es geht auch besser, ganz ehrlich, es geht auch besser, nicht das beste Jahr, das wir hier hatten, gar keine Frage, vielleicht wird es das nächste sein, seid dabei, bleibt dabei, haut rein und ... Erstmal eine schöne erste Januarwoche.
Schöne erste Januarwoche, macht's gut, haut rein.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, macht's gut, immer.